doté de nombreuses espaces verts et
d'équipements adaptés 50 ans en Yvelines
et le territoire de prédilection pour la
pratique du sport de nombreuses
associations y accueillent des
pratiquants passionnés qui s'illustrent
avec l'aide de la communauté
d'agglomération en compétition ou en
loisirs petit tour d'horizon en petite
foulée
47 stades et gymnase une base de loisirs
de golf un vélo Drôme qui accueille des
compétitions internationales et le siège
de la Fédération Française deux cyclisme
mais aussi un golf national ou se tient
chaque année la somme Open de France
dont la 98e édition débutera le 3
juillet et où se déroulera la Ryder Cup
en 2018 le Paris bastari qui rassemble
tous les quatre ans près de 5000
cyclotouristes du monde entier le sport
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ce sont de
grands événements populaires et
rassembleurs et c'est aussi l'affaire
d'un tissu associatif riche qui anime
l'agglomération quotidien et qu'il faut
bien entendu soutenir alors le sport à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines demeure un bon
axes majeur
d'abord parce qu'il est essentiel pour
la vie de nos concitoyens ensuite parce
que c'est un axe essentiel de la
visibilité de notre territoire et donc
ça participe à son attractivité donc ça
demeure bien évidemment un enjeu majeur
pour nous
alors oui c'est important pour la
communauté d'agglomération à deux titres
le premier c'est qu'il est important
qu'on puisse soutenir les clubs sur le
territoire d'habitude ce sont les
communes qui soutiennent les clubs sur
le cadre du territoire de la commune
mais on a également des clubs
intercommunaux donc l'agglomération se
concentre sur le soutien de ces clubs
intercommunaux en ce qui concerne les
subventions c'est un élément bien
évidemment complètement constructif de
la du fonctionnement du sport pour se
faire bien entendu les subventions
demeure un de nos axes de travail les
subventions demeurons bien évidemment
puisque sans cela le monde associatif ne
pourrait pas fonctionner un point
cependant il faut regarder comment ces
subventions sont aujourd'hui distribuées
peut-être en réorienter certaines dans
l'intérêt de la population c'est-à-dire
sur le sport qui est le plus
emblématique le plus représentatif d'un
maximum de nos concitoyens et puis qui
est un enjeu de territoires il faut
également ne pas oublier qu'à des
acteurs majeurs des subventions restent
et doivent demeurer les communes de 50
ans en Yvelines en termes de subventions
pour les divers soutiens que l'agglo
apporte au club c'est environ 500.000
euros par an c'est des composés en trois
aspects un aspect sur le
subventionnement au fonctionnement pour
les clubs on est de on est dans 2014 42
clubs sur le fonctionnement c'est
également le haut niveau individuel et
collectif cette année l'agglomération a
soutenu
huit clubs par équipe 34 athlètes au
niveau individuel et le dernier aspect
c'est le soutien aux manifestations
l'agglomération soutien cette année 26
manifestations sont des associations qui
peuvent être locales mais avec un
intérêt communautaire et les clubs
proprement communautaires c'est à dire
les ententes voilà les clubs interco on
a plusieurs disciplines à ce titre là on
a bien sûr l'athlétisme on a le
triathlon qui évolue aussi à très haut
niveau
ça signifie l'Entente Athlétique de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
il y a le syndic club un peu plus de 700
licenciés on est on est basé sur
plusieurs communes ça va être ça va être
dû en cours et en cours
il y a voisin niveau départemental où on
est le club numérique numéro 1 de par le
nombre de licenciés de parano à nos
performances
au niveau même national on est à
l'équipe une on a deux équipes donc
l'équipement national 1a donc juste sous
l'élite donc on fait partie des grands
clubs clubs français que ce soit en
crosse où on a été le club le plus
représenté cet hiver avec 42 qualifiés
au championnat de France il y a les
relais qui sont quatre fois 100 qui sont
très forts un individualité avec aïs
c'est-à-dire wara qui a porté le maillot
de l'équipe de France il y a Jeffrey les
vacs qui a aussi allé au championnat de
France élite en individuel sans 400
mètres l'année dernière il y a eu papa
babacar Diop qui a sur 400 mètres qui a
été championnat
à la perche le club est très bien
représenté au niveau national au niveau
de l'agglo on a on reçoit pas mal d'aide
que c'est au niveau des aides de
fonctionnement des aides pour les
sportifs de haut niveau que nous
possédons au sein du club il y a des
aides pour les courses que l'on va
organiser que soit le trailer hameau
ludique d'Élancourt nous avons des aides
des fois en termes matériels quand on va
en crosse pour avoir des temps pour
pouvoir s'abriter parce que en cross
l'hiver la météo n'est pas toujours
idéal donc c'est vrai qu'on reçoit pas
mal d'aide et c'est ce qui nous aide à
tourner et pouvoir pouvoir offrir en
toute cette panel de discipline aux
athlètes du club des aides précieuses
pour les clubs et des événements
sportifs précieux pour 50 ans en
Yvelines il y a les événements organisés
par les clubs en local que l'agglo
soutient par le biais de subventions ou
de la prise en charge de prestations de
la dotation en lot ça fait partie de
l'animation du territoire et ça fait
partie des missions d'agglomération il y
a un deuxième type de manifestation qui
sont effectivement les manifestations un
peu plus importantes qui peuvent se
dérouler au Vélodrome qui auront lieu ou
qui ont lieu déjà au golf national avec
l'Open de France l'Alstom en pleine de
France qui a lieu début juillet le
Paris-Brest-Paris tous ces événements
sont importants parce que il en va de
l'image aussi du territoire au-delà de
50 ans en Yvelines pour la région pour
pour la France aussi notamment avec la
Ryder Cup et surtout à l'international
en sachant que Ryder Cup je le rappelle
pour tous ceux qui nous regardent c'est
le deuxième événement le plus médiatisé
au monde ce que peut savent en France
mais que l'international tout le monde
connaît pas que les passionnés de vote
mais beaucoup de sportifs donc bien
entendu l'organisation de la Ryder Cup
2018 est un enjeu majeur pour la
visibilité du territoire en France mais
surtout à l'international et donc un
élément d'attractivité du territoire
c'est un enjeu majeur le deuxième point
c'est il ne faut pas l'oublier la
programmation du Vélodrome puisque nous
avons un outil extraordinaire avec le
vélodrome il faut aujourd'hui le faire
vivre et je dirais le faire mieux vivre
au-delà des simples événements cyclistes
ça peut-être dans pas péjoratif et pour
dire qu'il faut aller bien au delà il
faut l'ouvrir dans le monde de la
culture il faut faire fonctionner ce
lieu et donc lui donner accès à
l'ensemble des habitants et ensuite le
troisième point qui est un grand projet
majeur demeure l'étude du projet
d'aménagement de la skydom sur la
colline des en cours ce qui dôme qui
doit être installé mais qui doit se
faire dans de bonnes conditions entre
autres d'utilisation du site afin de ne
pas gêner les habitants et d'être là
aussi un phare pour l'ensemble de
l'agglomération au niveau de l'ensemble
de l'Île-de-France c'est donc là aussi
un projet
sur lequel l'ensemble de l'agglomération
est sur le président de Michel Laugier
ainsi que le vice-président charge des
grands projets Géral Favier vont
travailler avec moi pour faire en sorte
que ce soit une réussite comme le
Vélodrome et avec un fonctionnement qui
soit respectueux à la fois de
l'environnement et de ses habitants
et dans la lignée du premier conseil
communautaire de la nouvelle mandature
de la communauté d'agglomération qui
s'est déroulée le 26 avril dernier nous
vous présenterons chaque mois trois des
nouveaux vice-présidents de la casqui
aujourd'hui j'irai de Favier Armel
Aubret et Jean-Pierre Lefebvre je suis
retraité des jeunes depuis de nombreuses
années mais je consacre tout mon temps à
la politique et principalement à la
gestion de la commune d'Élancourt ce
depuis 18 ans
je suis premier adjoint de cette commune
et évidemment depuis le 26 avril je suis
l'un des vice-présidents de cette
communauté d'agglomération en charge des
grands projets et de la communication
cette délégation est conséquente dans la
mesure où les grands projets comme vous
le savez sont nombreux sur notre
territoire je reprends qui plus est
derrière Yves Muff qui a beaucoup
contribué à l'évolution et à la mise en
place d'un grand nombre de projets tels
que le vélodrome que je vais devoir
suivre mais nous avons également en
charge la futurie des recope qui est un
événement considérable pour notre
territoire et qui va nécessiter toute
mon énergie et puis il y a tout le
domaine de la communication avec bien
sûr en plus la fibre optique qui est un
élément très conséquent pour 50 ans en
Yvelines cette régie Antiope prend de
l'ampleur avec les accords qui sont
passés entre numericables et c'est faire
et nous allons avoir une charge de
travail aussi là très importante je suis
Armelle Aubriet je suis élue depuis 25
ans à la mairie de Montigny où j'ai
occupé au départ de mandats sur la
culture et puis j'entame mon troisième
mandat sur les finances
à la communauté d'agglo je vais donc
avoir le budget chez la vice-président
sur budget et la commission du budget
mais en fait je travaille à la j'étais
élue déjà à la communauté d'agglo depuis
6 ans les enjeux au niveau budget et ils
sont le même les mêmes que ceux des
communes c'est-à-dire la baisse des des
revenus en particulier de la de la DGF
puis en fait aussi le fait que la
communauté d'agglo avec la réforme de la
TP émue aussi ses revenus baissés ou
d'au moins liés à des dotations de
l'État qui vont baisser après on a des
grands en jeu aussi qui sont la
codiscution du pacte financier et en
même temps il faut qu'on ramène la
communauté d'agglo comme une communauté
d'agglos normal donc il faut qu'on
baisse la dette il y aura aussi tous les
enjeux financiers liés à
l'agrandissement du périmètre de la
communauté d'agglo qui doit être fait
pour dans un an et demi
Jean-Pierre Lefèvre élu à Élancourt
depuis trois mandats et j'attaque donc
le quatrième au titre de la ville avec
une délégation développement économique
et emploi et au titre des lieux
communautaire à l'Agglo de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines cette fois-ci
je suis donc nommé vice-président en
charge de l'habitat
c'est une délégation qui fait partie des
délégations obligatoires de la
Communauté de l'agglomération pourquoi
parce que la guitare c'est une des
fonctions qui permet depuis la création
de la Communauté d'Agglo de gérer la
bonne répartition de de des habitations
de des constructions qui se font sur le
territoire afin d'avoir un équilibre
social un équilibre en accession soit la
propriété soit en location et il nous
faut aussi répondre aux besoins des
entreprises qui font travailler à peu
près 70 000 salariés sur le territoire
et ses salariés cherchent de plus en
plus à occuper des logements proches de
leur travail et donc nous ayons par les
fonctions qui nous sont données à ce bon
équilibre à cette bonne répartition sur
le territoire et à répondre aux attentes
des étudiants des jeunes travailleurs
des familles des familles avec enfants
les seniors qui sont seuls et que on
essaye par des programmes aussi
d'accueillir dans des résidences
services des résidences de retraite etc
un dossier que vous pouvez retrouver
dans le petit Quentin du mois de juin si
qu'un article qui vous expliquera
comment optimiser votre CV et le
portrait du batteur trappiste David
pourra dire Duteil à très bientôt dans
bien vivre